you did not think this is creepy don't  touch me  this is wrong you didn't think any of  that no I didn't think any of that it  was again the feeling was out of all the  kids in the world right Here I am  and Michael shows me and he also told me  that you know I've never done this with  anybody else yeah yeah so that was more  - Wow I'm very special right he chooses  me and he loves me James you're nodding  in agreement to what he's saying  yeah I mean that's all the same you know  he did the same thing to me as well you  think there are other boys out there  Wade yeah I believe there are many other  boys that Michael abused I find it hard  to believe that he had boys around for  any other reason than to sexually abuse  them